[Musique]
comme un retour à la vie d'avant dans
les rues d'israël
masques tombent et les visages
apparaissent désormais tout entier 1500
euros c'est l'amendé que risqueront les
voyageurs qui ne respecteront pas la
quarantaine
une quarantaine de dix jours instaurée
cette la semaine dernière pour tous ceux
qui atterrissent en france en provenance
du brésil d'argentine dû chili et
d'afrique du sud en extérieur le port du
masque n'est plus obligatoire il leur
est seulement en intérieur par exemple
dans les commerces ou les transports en
commun vous devez vous devrez rester
isolés pendant dix jours et il y aura
des contrôles par la police par la
gendarmerie qui permettront de vérifier
que vous êtes bien dans le lieu où vous
devez vous isolez je le réclame depuis
les plus d'un an
à l'époque on m'a traité de tous les
noms je racontais n'importe quoi que
c'était impossible
maintenant la question c'est de
l'appliquer correctement et c'est le
problème des frontières intérieures
emmanuel macron s'accorde une trêve avec
le co vide pour s'engager sur un nouveau
front
la sécurité en visite dans ce
commissariat de montpellier
le président arrive les bras chargés de
promesses emmanuel macron promet plus de
moyens la création d'une école de guerre
un beau choc pour améliorer la formation
des forces de l'ordre et renouvelle un
de ses engagements
dix mille nouveaux policiers sur le
territoire d'ici la fin de son mandat
nouvelles violences contre eux des
policiers s'étaient cette nuit à
tourcoing vous voyez les images ont ce
moment images spectaculaires de cette
agression des forces de l'ordre quand
vous démontre les empreintes deal quand
vous démantelé un trafic est un réseau
qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya en face une réaction il se
reconstitue oui je dirai en face aux
réactions des agressions contre les
forces de l'ordre donc c'est certain que
on perturbe un écosystème et que ça peut
entraîner un certain nombre de violences
on va se mettre sur le côté on ne vous
dira donc arrêté là dans les bâtiments
ils ont reculé on va la faire là bas de
l'autre côté les reculs et décalé c'est
vous on va se mettre dans l'autre sens
reculé que marlène schiappa dit nous
voulons sortir de la tenaille entre d'un
côté les identitaires d'extrême droite
et de l'autre les indigéniste et et
europe ecologie les verts on est
aujourd'hui de la part de sept ministres
de la part de certains ministres sur le
registre de l'insultent la bonne idée
signée jadot
[Rires]
j'appelle le président de la république
et le premier ministre à faire en sorte
que le débat dans notre pays
sur un sujet aussi sensible ne soit pas
un outil de propagande
oui je suis en rage d'abord quand je lis
d'un côté qu'il y a trois milliardaires
de plus dans notre pays et que de
l'autre il eut à 3 millions de personnes
de plus qui tombe sous la pauvreté et le
résultat est sans appel
en un an les gouvernements ont autant
emprunté qu'au cours des huit années
précédentes la dette publique mondiale
représentait 70% du pib en 2010 neufs
ont atteint les 84 % en 2020 il y en
france quarante deux milliardaires qui
ont un patrimoine de 500 milliards
d'euros et il y a de l'autre côté 12
millions de personnes en france qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté en
france la dette est évaluée aujourd'hui
à plus de 3000 milliards de dollars et
118% du pib ce qui fait de l'hexagone le
plus gros emprunteur d'europe
incroyable image ça se passe en floride
aux états unis où le pilote de cet avion
datant de la seconde guerre mondiale qui
participait à un spectacle à rien a dû
amerrir en urgence en raison d'un
problème mécanique qui sera à quelques
mètres seulement des touristes
toujours dans le domaine spatial
d'hélicoptères de la nasa à jean louis
qui a survolé la planète mars
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois qu'un
engin motorisé survol ainsi une autre
planète on voit l'engin faire du
surplace d'abord environ 3 mètres
d'altitude puis s'opposer sur la surface
de mars